فنلندا واشلندا تحت اللان صداره العالم في
مؤشر السعاده لكن لديهما ايضا احد اعلى
معدلات استخدام مضادات الاكتئاب الهند
تتذيل ترتيب مؤشر سعاده الاممي في المرتبه
المئه والسادسه والعشرين وفي مؤشر اخر
حصلت على مرتبه اعلى كثيرا في مقياس
السعاده فما سر الاختلاف الحادث ترتيب
الدول على مؤشرات السعاده ولماذا يتهم
مقيم السعاده
شبكه حلول التنميه المستدامه تنشر تقريرا
سنويا عن السعاده يعتمد على استطلاعات
تجريها مؤسسه
تستخلص النتائج استنادا الى اجابات بضعه
الاف من المشاركين عن تقييم حياتهم
الشخصيه بمقياس 10 درجات خمس دول تحتل
دائما مقدمه هذه الاستطلاعات وهي فنلندا
والدنمارك وايسلندا واسرائيل وهولندا ثم
تعامل مشترك بين هذه الدول وفق ما لاحظه
الباحثون وهو الناتج الاجمالي المرتفع
للفرد ومؤشرات الاقتصاد العاليه في فنلندا
كان نصيب الفرد 49 الف دولار من الناتج
المحلي عام 2019 لكن هذه الحسابات لا تصلح
لتصنيف السعاده وفق الخبراء فهي نتيجه
افتراضيه لتقسيم اجمالي الناتج المحلي على
عدد السكان
فلا تظهر تفاوت الدخل والانقسام الطبقي
بين فقراء واغنياء في الولايات المتحده
مثلا يكافح 60% من السكان لدفع ديونهم في
كل شهر ويعيش 38 مليون شخص في فقر وهناك
معضله اخرى في مقياس السعاده الذي تتبناه
الامم المتحده وهو تجاهل الاسباب المظلمه
لارتفاع مستوى السعاده في بعض الدول والذي
يقوم في كثير من الاحيان على تعاسه دول او
مجتمعات اخرى فبريطانيا التي تاتي في
المرتبه السابعه عشر بين اسعد دول العالم
بانت ازدهارها جزئيا على استعمال كثير من
دول العالم وبلجيكا صاحبه المركز التاسع
عشر نهبت خيرات جمهوريه الكونغو ديمقراطيه
وبمثال اقرب الى عالمنا العربي نرى
اسرائيل جاءت في المرتبه الرابعه اما
الصينيون الذين تعرضوا لطرد القسري من
اراضيهم فكانوا في المرتبه الخامسه
والتسعين واخيرا تمت عله شائعه في مؤشر
سعاده الاممي وهي تباين معنى الرفاهيه
ومفهومها بين الناس من دوله الى اخرى وهذا
ما يعرف بالتحيز الثقافي بحسب دراسه نشرت
عام 2023 فادوات تقييم السعاده التي تركز
عليها استطلاعات مؤسسه تتبنى انماط الحياه
الغربيه التي قد تختلف تماما لدى المواطن
شرقي ثمه معايير اخرى لمعرفه مستوى
السعاده قد تكون اكثر دقه تقوم على تقييم
توازن بين العمل والحياه وبهذا المعيار
تحتل الصين صداره الدول الاكثر سعاده
وانتم حدثونا عن مستوى السعاده في بلدكم
[موسيقى]